It seems that the same case will be multiplied by a factor of five
.
But
it's suddenly napalm from
1x, isn't it?  I can't
measure the difference when I'm eating, but when I go to the bathroom the next day, I
get angry.
No
, I'm trying to make foreign friends
too No, wait a minute, next time
I'm thinking of going to a gaijin bar and talking to someone
I see, but hey, I
really want to talk to a foreigner I'm so happy Stop
Stone  Isn't it strange to say that I
already have 6
friends?
I've been talking to a foreigner for 20 minutes, so that's right, but if the company
is Japanese, what kind of situation
would it be
that I'm talking to
a foreigner?  Do you think you'll be satisfied or not?
Saying that you did
n't think about it, I think foreigners who speak Japanese don't look like foreigners
.
Don't you have a katana or is this different?
I'm bored with my current life, so I want new stimuli.
It's
not like there's going to be a catastrophe or a sudden dream-like path
, so if you want to make foreign friends and really get some stimulation, you should probably eat 10
times more curry and taste a bit of hell,
doesn't it
?  I will but
then I won't say anything me